i called my dad immediately because i am
um i'm based in london
so immediately i called him and i was
everything okay and by then
everything was fine um and then we
didn't have any contact anymore um but
we knew
we had known from like her landlord that
she was picked up but we
had no idea when that happened and where
she had brought
uh where she was broad and basically um
because all the
all the hospitals were also evacuated
and she's got basically she got like an
emergency brace that where she would
press if she's ever in danger um
so we had no idea where she was um
and we had like i mean the whole family
was trying to reach her we reported her
as missing
and then i saw on facebook there's
obviously this sort of crisis response
where everyone was trying to help people
and i thought
i'd try my luck and obviously put the
photo of us up
and with all her like where she lives if
anyone had heard anything
like hoping i guess someone that might
have like
been in the emergency accommodations or
hospitals had seen her face
and i had such a great response i had a
lot of shares people were so
helpful they asked their friends they
asked their family to see if she was
there
so i went sort of like by an elimination
i guess and then in the evening i should
say i can't believe
she hasn't been found so i just i just
actually i just looked on google maps
and i looked um in the circle around
parnoina availa i just looked
where there are hospitals so i ended up
at like one o'clock in the morning
calling up about
20 hospitals until
one person told me she had been
transferred to a retirement home
and at two o'clock in the morning i
suddenly got
then the message that she was safe and
sound and
asleep and it was probably the most
amazing thing ever
so um thanks to all the people that
helped me that checked it was like i
can't believe so many people were so
helpful
but she's safe and sound um you know
it's so
good to hear i was going to say it's so
good to hear
a happy ending and a good news story
amongst all the devastation and
horror that's been going on here just
tell me a little bit about
your graham cause she's 86 years old
she's pretty
vulnerable and she lives in an area that
has been hit by the flooding
yeah so she's she's 86 um
so she's lived there basically all her
life um i've i've actually just talked
to her i just came off the phone
with her and she told me that it was
actually really scary so she wasn't
picked up
before it happened so she she like woke
up basically and she was like
up to here and water and she she tried
to obviously
use this bracelet or whatever and it
didn't work and
she was saying she was so scared and
then she just called for help and people
like smashing in her windows to get her
out
um and i mean she's the most amazing
woman i feel like
she's indestructible she she will do
anything and she's
still being so positive she knows her
flat is probably not really recoverable
but she's just really glad
we found her and she was crying i mean
my uncle's with her now and they were
saying like she was crying when we
finally found her
and um no i think she would be okay she
can stay in the retirement room for a
little bit
um and then we'll probably try find a
flat for her and then
we'll get on the cleaning i guess off
her old flat but the whole street she
lives
quite close to the river well well done
you for being so
yeah well done you for being so
determined to find her it sounds like
your detective work was
spot on and this is an area that you
know
your heart must go out to people who
have had their homes and their lives
destroyed here
yeah it's it's it's devastating it's
also the town where my dad grew up
um when he had this whole childhood and
it's just it's just crazy
i was i was only there like about two
months ago and
like seeing the photos online it's like
a place where we always go
when i'm home and i just can't imagine
like somewhere that happening also it's
the most beautiful area in germany i
just
yeah all these lovely people i just
it's just horrible like i can't even
imagine